[Music]
Disneyland I'm a big fan of Disneyland
Fran's of Disneyland I genuinely love
Disneyland I've been a bunch of times
I've got the Mickey hat
fun fact they won't let you embroider
the word Petey poops on it pretty
disappointing for old PB poofy go figure
and let me tell you I think there are
two main ways you can navigate a day at
a theme park one you can over plan or
two you can freestyle and I say you
gotta go freestyle freestyle all the way
baby
every time over planning a trip listen
to me to a theme park it makes you miss
the point of the theme part which is to
have fun
that's the theme fun but people go
around like oh boy we're going Saturday
big day big day the way I gotta plan out
I'm looking like a 15-hour day we're
gonna walk in that Park 5 a.m. 5 a.m.
what is this law school if I'm not
writing a guidebook or doing a Travel
Channel special co-starring Guy Fieri
I'm not going at 5 a.m. I'm waltzing in
at noon you want to know how many rides
I averaged on a trip to Disneyland 2/3
if I'm ambitious
pirates Haunted Mansion pineapple ice
cream cone that's it the third one's
arrived for your taste buds that's all I
want
cuz I'm sauntering baby you look at me
from above I look like an amoeba under a
microscope
she's enjoying my life
and that's it it's amazing not only are
you enjoying the park at a relaxed pace
taking pictures with men dressed like
mice and mend race just like lady mice
management told me went on many I can't
talk you also get to calmly observe all
the stressed panic people and be
grateful that you're not one of them you
know those people that need to get
pictures with all of the characters
waiting in line for 45 minutes to snap a
pic with Mickey Minnie Donald the
a-listers I'm off on the lesser-known
streets getting selfies with the easily
accessible c-listers Gaston the sheepdog
from Peter Pan and an Asian lady who
thought the monorail was a ride and I
thought she was jasmine
a whole new world yeah
what I'm saying is this whether it's
Disneyland their life stop forcing the
most out of an experience just enjoy
whatever happens you over plan you miss
all the actual fun go freestyle when you
go freestyle your only thoughts are what
a great time you're having and if I pee
when a wave hits on Splash Mountain will
anyone notice either way it sounds like
a story to me and over planners are
always worried about the lines yeah
there's gonna be lines and relax
you can either let them stress you out
or you can enjoy them they move they
move and even when they don't they've
installed little TVs with movies that
tie-in to the ride you can watch each is
a cool
Mario Lopez has shown us how to buckle
up that's a real one that's not on his
IMDB and the line is where you get to
meet people and have fun you get to meet
the sweet southern guy who's there for
the first time and his heart is
overflowing with joy because he's
obsessed with finding Nemo that's who
you wanted me just like yeah that orange
fish is missing and the lesbian fish in
the Jewish fish are gonna find there
I get worried he's not gonna make it
every time where else you gonna meet
that man it felt like there should have
been something there but I had nothing
funny thing lines and the food do sure
you could be the guy trying to game the
system just like hey I brought a tuna
fish sandwich from home no way I'm
paying 8 bucks for fries listen you got
bled dry paying for admission and
parking but you're gonna draw the line
at fries I say pocket tuna tomorrow $8
fries today because Disneyland aren't
just any old fries they're any old fries
that cost $8 they give them fun names
like miski whipped uh it's okay they add
it it's fine it's gonna be fine it's
gonna look perfect but you get to see
this
[Applause]
they give them fun names like Mickey
whiskers hard to say I'll just say
Mickey whiskers already said a lot of
words Mickey whiskers late in the
monologue hard to say cashier hands them
to your like fried up by the mouse man
himself but you can see in the back they
got a huge Costco Oh need a bag dump
them into a deep fryer
this truly is a magical kingdom I'm
gonna I love a sea Lister I'm not saying
it's not a ripoff it's a ripoff but go
with the flow over-planning leads to
disappointment like the people who try
and get the good seats for the fireworks
good seats they're fireworks
they're in the goddamn sky everywhere is
a good seat and then there's the guy
that makes his family miss the fireworks
because he doesn't want to get stuck in
traffic oh there he goes
how about this you fascist stay for the
fireworks and get stuck in traffic and
while you're sitting there gridlocked
you can finally do the thing you're over
planning ass avoided doing all day
spending some time with your family so
put on the soundtrack from frozen tell
everybody to sing along and let it go
from Parks and Rec the hilarious Adam
Scott it's going to be here live in the
studio
[Applause]
[Music]